it's clear that something is changing in
erie harbor
so why is magic hour chronicle the only
paper reporting on this
the adults around here won't do anything
about it then i will
oh my god hildy shut up in season two
hildy definitely has a lot of clues to
follow with richie but also going off
into
an environmental case
could you tell me if you have anything
on a strange event last night
now you know how i feel about you but i
can't be your source anymore
i love the dynamic and how it shifted in
season two that we're all working
together to
find out what happened kill this
relationship with men you get to see
them more as the journalists
duo walk me through your evidence right
now you're feeling that you think the
facts
matt sees a lot of himself and his
daughter so it doesn't take much for
hilda to ignite a spark in his passion
for journalism
that's his story izzy gets to come and
work with me
at the law firm she's sort of starting
to have a
stronger sense of the world around her
and she's speaking out alongside her
sister
they say what do you know about
injustice yeah well i'll tell you what
we know
she gains a lot of confidence this
season if she finds out who she
actually wants to be are you gonna say
something
no this is easiest thing
there's a real love within the lisco
family and also within
the friendships that we've forged in
these two seasons
we've definitely bonded so much
this secret that richie had it's not
going to stay buried
i have a plan dr
i know that look so let's skip the part
where i don't want to do it and go
straight to the part where you convinced
me to
you